ps5 might be getting a pro controller
and todd howard reveals fallout 5 plans
according to a tryhard guides report
from tom henderson sony is releasing a
playstation 5 pro controller with
removable analog sticks and rear back
paddles similar to the xbox elite
controller the report says the code name
for the pro controller is hunt and
henderson claims to have seen images of
a prototype the alleged new playstation
5 pro controller will also have new
grips to help users hold it and these
also may be removable and considering
sony's big push into the pc world we can
assume that the new controller will work
for pc as well according to the report
sony will reveal new hardware but not a
new console at the end of june though
it's unclear if this rumored new
controller may be a part of that there's
also a rumor that suggests sony may
reveal the release date for god of war
ragnarok at some type of end of june
briefing but take that with a grain of
salt and speaking of games without a
release date bethesda's todd howard has
confirmed that the studio plans to work
on fallout 5 following the completion of
the elder scrolls 6. in a new interview
howard spoke about what the studio has
planned after starfield and he touched
on the progress of the elder scrolls 6
by stating that the project was still in
pre-production suggesting that it's
still a while away from launch in the
same breath howard confirmed that
fallout 5 is planned as the next game
after that the elder scrolls 6 was
announced in 2018 just 3 years after the
launch of fallout 4. in 2015 bethesda
decided to announce fallout 4 only 6
months before its eventual release with
the studio moving on to starfield in
some capacity in late 2015 according to
howard that means starfield will have
been in development for over seven years
if it sticks to its 2023 release date
bethesda did start these projects under
its former publishers and max media
however with microsoft now acting as its
new parent company there's no indication
yet if this could change how the studio
operates on new projects going forward
or whether multiple games can be
developed in parallel thanks to
additional resources but if you need
something to play sooner then you might
want to register to play in the upcoming
overwatch 2 beta sign up begins tomorrow
june 16th and gameplay will begin on
june 28th the beta will feature a new
map and the newest character junker
queen and just in case you need another
reason to be excited for tomorrow square
enix plans to host a final fantasy 7
25th anniversary broadcast at 3 p.m
pacific time this will be a shorter
event than many of the ones from last
week with the live stream planned to run
for only 10 minutes although square enix
says that it will be packed with lots of
information for final fantasy vii fans
to enjoy whether that means the
long-awaited final fantasy 7 remake part
2 will finally surface or something else
remains to be seen and now i'd like to
take a small moment of silence for
everyone's favorite chrome downloader
internet explorer
today microsoft finally pulled the plug
on the program
and the world may never be the same
please
in the comments
share your favorite safe for work
memories of internet explorer
and i'll see you tomorrow
you